hey guys it is the ninth of every today
my name is justin mcconnell and you're
tuned into ghost what news it seems that
people were pretty keen to buy up
resident evil HD remaster so keen in
fact the game is breaking PSN and capcom
sales records capcom's remaster of the
2002 remake of the very popular zombie
rific 1996 game is now the fastest
selling digital title in Capcom's
history across western markets as well
as becoming the biggest selling day 1
digital title on PlayStation Network
sony also announced that res HD was the
top-selling ps3 and ps4 game of january
even though it only came out on the 20th
a very reasonably priced title is only
running gamers 20 bucks and is also on
xbox one 360 and pc one can only hurt
that this serves as enough encouragement
for capcom to give rezzy to the remix
treatment as well along with buying
Rosie HD it seems that more than a few
of you spent time in the battlefield
hardline beta since it's cracked 6
million players for reference that's
more players than those that were
playing the destiny beta which maxed out
at 4.6 million players though that was
only on consoles battlefield hardline
executive producer Steve pub cortex has
expressed his enthusiasm for your
interest and asks gamers to keep the
feedback coming the game will be
released on march 17 in the US the beta
officially ends today but the exact time
varies by platform and region so you
might be able to squeeze a few more
hours in if you haven't had the chance
yet and in carbine used about crappy
people another SWAT team raid
a game was home during a twitch stream
thanks to an unknown viewer who trolled
with him and emergency services and some
people think that's funny apparently the
streamer in question was Joshua Peters
who has been sent out a message
heartbreakingly explaining how police
pointed guns as his little brothers
thanks to the anonymous individual who
decided to swat his dream not only is
swatting abhorrent and vile it's also
illegal while no one has been arrested
in regard to this particular case a 19
year old faces up to five years in
prison having been charged for
instigating numerous flooding incidents
in Las Vegas let me know down in the
comments what you reckon the punishment
for swatting should be and why you can
head to gain swap for news on how to get
online multiplayer for free on ps4 and
what my gist episode for tips on how to
kick ass at a bowl those are all the
things that I wanted to tell you about
today i'll be back same time tomorrow
with a bunch more news so check back
with me then